hey everyone Dave Volo here and in
today's video we're going over probably
one of the most hyped fights in all of
manga and of course anime history this
here is the illustrious and freaking
elastic if you know what I mean by
between the two Emperors of the sea
Luffy and kaido obviously this is a huge
battle that stops and starts over a
literally massive length of time with
Luffy First missing kaido on the
mainland then like 80 chapters later of
course up on onikishima but what we are
going to do today is take out all of
their unnecessary information in between
the fights so that we can form together
hopefully what seems like a constant
massive battle between Luffy and kaido
they also highlight some of the features
and best moments throughout this Arc as
well of course if you want more anime
and manga story styled explain content
just like this but for a variety of
different series perhaps like even all
of wano explained over a ridiculously
long video then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on it as well as it really
helps out with YouTube's silly old
algorithm and pushes my content to a
bunch of new amazing people but anyway
enough of that let's kit right into the
midst of the battle and when I say midst
of the battle I literally mainly
freaking High Pass moment everyone had
been waiting for where Luffy finally
spots kaido after he annihilates Odin's
castle with a null yard attack like I
can't remember the exact date when I saw
this but what I do remember is the
absolute hype me and all of my mates
felt when we first saw the dragon that
was kaido soaring throughout the sky so
as we kick things off into the moments
right before the first battle we find
kaido literally passing right by Luffy
enlar as he unleashes a devastating bowl
of breath at Odin's castle that
completely obliterates US law then
quickly notes that Luffy is no longer
beside him and the people of Curry
Village watch as Luffy jumps over kaido
and uses his gamalgamonu elephant gun to
hit the emperor directly on his head
initiating the first conflict kardo's
Dragon form slams onto the ground after
being heads in the kid by Luffy reaching
the ground Luffy yells to his crew and
asks if they managed to escape kaido's
attack Luffy hears that several of
kaido's subordinates discover Lady speed
who was heavily injured fearing for
tama's Life Luffy asks speed if she was
able to get tummer out of this city
safely he then learns that kardo spotted
them and despite doing her best to
protect armor kaido had managed to
injure them both with his attack angered
by this Luffy beats himself up for not
going along with him and prepares to
attack kaido law frantically tells Luffy
that they need to check on their
respective Crews and berates him for
jeopardizing their plans yet Luffy
ignores law and yells at kaido getting
his attention even though kaido is
completely faded right now off the
trinks that he's been drinking
beforehand he still recognizes Luffy and
comments how he's finally arrived and
why no he then unleashes another blast
towards Luffy incinerating the immediate
area around him however Lady speed is
able to propel Luffy into the ear
towards kaido's I'll leave all
immediately Luffy activates Gear 3 and
pummels kaido with a volley of numerous
punches well down below the remaining
bass Pirates are shocked to see kaido
taking such a tremendous basing and he
falls from the sky transforming back
into his human form Luffy rushes forward
activating gear 4 as he resumes his
attack however Karu gets back on his
feet to the surprise of everyone glaring
at Luffy cutting swings as cannabo and
Strikes Luffy then seeming to dash
forward he mocks his revelation of
becoming the pirate king as Luffy soars
through the air knocked completely
unconscious from the blow
so yeah good old Luffy thought the
recent gains he develops before wanna
would have been enough to take down the
big man himself but obviously the
completely faded cardo of the sake he
was drinking didn't even feel a punch
from him mainly just due to the almost
kentatonic State he was in okay so with
Luffy getting completely ganked a whole
bunch of super random odor stuff happens
in between the time that the first meet
happens and the time that they arrive
atop skull Dome to finally face him like
being taught by the absolute G hirokuro
while being stuck in udon prison with
another member of the Supernova
generation the mentally unstable useless
kid or what happens with Zorro and all
of the other members of these straw hats
during the time in preparation up till
the main day but yeah we ain't going
over any of that for now now finally
after for what US Margaritas seemed like
an infinite amount of time and probably
as well for the anime side Luffy and
Zoro reached the roof of oneigashima
along with a useless kid killer and lore
where they confront kaido and big mum
who are awaiting them Luffy no notices
something and starts walking towards the
two as kaido tells big mum what Luffy
told him previously that he was going to
be the pirate king big mom also aired
how he talked back to her so she wants
an apology God I actually dislike big
mum so much I don't even know why I
honestly think it's just because you're
gross ass exterior is a representation
of a messed up interior in the way that
she thinks anyway anyway to this
surprise though Luffy ignores them and
walks past them over to the scabbards
and izo who were defeated previously and
left Beeson on the floor kado turns to
look at Luffy in demands he say what he
said to them previously to their faces
Luffy however continues to ignore them
and instead apologizes to Kenny mon for
arriving late he looks at the injured
Samurai and Canyon distrautly says that
he can't leave things as they are or he
will never be able to face Odin in the
afterlife he asks Luffy to shoulder
their burden and save wano who agrees
citing that it is the land of his
friends an annoyed Kato proceeds to
raise his Club to strike Luffy but Luffy
asks law to move everyone away with his
devil fruit which he does so he then
jumps back into the air dodging kaido's
strike as he transforms into his Gear 3
State as he does so he thinks back to
when the mink tribe revealed that rhizo
was safe and that they would never sell
out their allies momonosuke's tears as
he yelled that he wanted to take down
kaido kinemon revealing that he had
traveled through time yasuway's
execution here guru's tears of joy and
kinemon revealing the truth of Odin's
death then he proceeds to strike kaido
with an insane new ability like it's so
freaking clean called Gamo gum on a red
rock slamming him onto the ground and
actually causing him to bleed big dumb
is left in disbelief at the site of
kaido getting knocked down as Luffy
introduces himself as the one who will
surpass the two of them and become the
pirate king hearing this big come yells
at Luffy for his declaration saying he
doesn't know what it means to be pirate
King Zora and kid are surprised as he
has punched work and killer says that
they might actually have a Fighting
Chance cardo however wonders what the
hell happened after he defeated him back
in Corey since he only knows a few
people capable of fighting him in that
moment he sees Shadows of Odin
Whitebeard Shanks Roger and rocks behind
Luffy causing him to smirk with
anticipation Luffy uses his observation
haki to foresee kaido's thunderbagua
that moves too fast and Luffy still ends
up getting hurt though he is still able
to stand this time watch kaido admires
big mum tries to use Prometheus to
attack Luffy but Zoro ends up using
kennemon's Firefox style to cut
Prometheus in half as Prometheus
reforgers Zoro Minds Luffy that they are
fighting the two Empress of the sea so
they can't afford to drop their guards
before Carter can strike Luffy again
Lord uses shambles to save him bringing
Luffy closer to lore Big mum his
Prometheus Fireballs of fire what she
calls Heavenly Bond bonds as the
Fireballs get closer Luffy stupidly and
cockingly says whoever reacts first to
the Fireballs is a loser Lawton kid
refused to play the game which causes
Luffy to call them both losers however
both Zoro and Keller attacked kaido who
praises them for their strength though
Zora realizes he needs to release more
of Emma's power Luffy law and kid get
back up and as Luffy goes into gear
fourth kid creates a huge suit of
chunked metal and Lord prepares a room
cardo laughs and calls the three of them
monsters in their own right and as he
says this Luffy punches him with the
Gumble gumbo no Kong gun kid hits him
with Punk Vise and gets several large
rocks dropped on him by Law's tact
ability after a brief pause kaido
emerges from the rubble in his Dragon
form and joins big mom in the air riding
Zeus and Prometheus kaido tells the five
pirates that it would be a shame for him
to kill all of them but he has no choice
he and big mum also plan on taking their
crew Trisha and Pawnee glyphs and says
that whoever wins this battle will
become one step closer to becoming the
true pirate king paru uses his
demolition Gus to unleash several wind
blades on the group but law uses his
power to avoid them killer also jumps
out of the way while kid gets struck but
despite Killer's worry kid tells him he
is okay since the Golem is made out of
junk that he can reattach Zoro deflects
the wind blade while Luffy Dodges them
getting close to kaido and striking him
with gumbo gamma no Kong rifle which
injures him again kid moves underneath
kardo and grabs his head with his robot
slamming him into the floor with slam
Gibson which also causes him some pain
lore Maneuvers around kaido with his
powers before stabbing him with a gamma
knife saying that while he has never
seen the insides of a dragon before he
assumes his heart was where he stabbed
kardo shakes them off and admits they
learned how tough as defenses
acknowledging them is more than just
Mindless fools relying on guards killer
starts running along kaido's body saying
that he just needs to cut past his
scales to the inside then uses
scythersonic to damage him from the
inside however Kelly gets struck by
begmom's Indra who declares that as long
as they are under the Open Sky no one
will escape from her admits that the
group is annoying but before he can
Chomp on killer Luffy strikes him with
gamma gum and orina Schneider cutter
prepares to use bolo breath again but
Zoro tells law to move him into the ear
what she does reluctantly he cuts the
fire with blaze slice to protect Luffy
while using hariu and kayin on kaido
geez I actually suck at Japanese names
by the way hence why I've tried using
all of the viz attacks in this uh and
the story and this and this battle going
on right here big mum warns kaido to
dodge because the sword Zoro was using
is no ordinary sword unfortunately Zoro
misses his attack and ends up cutting
off one of the horns atop of this skull
dome which is freaking insane like Zoro
out here straight up trying to murkado
before Luffy can Zoro then gets struck
by big mum's god of lightning tingen
while the others try to block it Luffy
gets struck as well but comes out of it
unscathed much to Big mom's confusion
Luffy yells to Big mum that he is rubber
so her lightning will not work on him he
then tells her that she will pay for
striking everyone the way that she did
but suddenly Luffy gets hit by kaido's
bolo breath attack fucado's equal
surprise though Luffy comes out
unscathed as well claiming that it was
his gut that protected him he then
strikes icardo with the Gamu Gama no
Kong Gatling Luffy finishes pummeling
kaido knocking him into the ground as
big mum watches in horror after
finishing Luffy deflates and returns to
normal landing on the ground as the
others watch kid asks when Karu managed
to strike him but lore explains to kid
that what he is seen as the side effect
of Luffy's gear 4 form and now he won't
be able to use his haki for 10 whole
minutes kid acknowledges the cost of
that strength but says that as long as
it did some damage to kardo it wouldn't
matter big mom laughs if that was the
extent of Luffy's strength and uses
happy Mother's Blaze to attack him Zoro
however manages to grab him and save him
from the attack as big mum demands he
hand him over law gets in closer to Big
mum and uses his counter-shock ability
to damage her kado gets back up and sees
kid and killer charging for him and
Alicia's is Dragon twister ability to
blow everyone away Zoro comments that
Carter is practically a natural disaster
as he loses his grip on Luffy who flies
into the air and gets chomped on by
kaido Angry Zoro demands kaido release
his captain as he unleashes his three
sword style black rope Dragon Twister on
kaido forcing him to release Luffy while
getting damaged in the process kaido who
since this strange haki he felt from
before again finally deduces that Zorro
was indeed using Odin's sword as the
pain felt similar Kota decides to take
on Zora's twister challenge as he
unleashes a stronger variation of the
black rope Dragon twister kultatsumaki
kaifu which everyone tries to dodge
after this attack it then skips away
from the Battle For a Moment leaving us
with the complete sense of unknown until
it returns but as it returns it now
reveals kaido who's changed into his
hybrid form as he tells big mum that
this battle has started to get
interesting to which she agrees okay
like literally right after the hybrid
caught her reveal and a game flies
around the battlefield and in good old
odor fashion he spends a nice amount of
time building up everyone else's fight
in unison with the main rooftop battle
during the time that it does Skip away
the battle that is going on between
Luffy and kaido continues so honestly it
is completely unknown almost what
happened over this time other than that
they would definitely throw in some
hands for sure anyways back atop this
skull Dome now Luffy who has recovered
over the last few minutes is blowing
into a rock between Zoro and kurd the
two wonder how they are supposed to
defeat the two Emperors because it looks
like none of their attacks are working
Luffy says that they are because kaido
and big mom are human so they have to be
feeling the pain of their attacks he
tries to attack again but is blown back
into the wall killer wonders how we can
call the two of them human but Luffy
says that a losing attitude isn't going
to help as zoru demands he come up with
a new plan law suggests that they try
and split the two of them up which Zoro
and category worth as kid says they're
fighting the two of them is like hell
Luffy says then if that is true then he
has been to Hell and back a few times
from a distance kado looks on at Luffy
and tells him that his eyes never seem
to lose their fire big dumb suggests to
kaido that they use a combined attack to
finish off the five Pirates kid asks why
law cannot just use his devil fruit
powers to send one of them away causing
law to retort if he could he would have
already but the reason he cannot is
because both of the ahaki is too strong
for him to move directly could says that
they would just have to tear them apart
as Luffy warns everyone about an
incoming attack kaido and big mum ready
their weapons while insulting each other
and unleash a flying attack called
conquest of the Seas to their surprise
Zoro does his best to block the attack
telling everyone to run the massive
deflected attack destroys a chunk of the
island but all of them managed to
survive the blast which the two Emperors
notice law asks Zora if he's okay and he
says he barely is could tell zuru that
he was not able to buy them much time
but also thanks hun for blocking the
attack meanwhile Luffy attacks kaido
when kaido Dodges the punch Luffy smiles
and asks kaido if he's dodging because
he knows it can hurt him Karu swings at
Luffy with his cannabo as Luffy uses
haki to protect himself Karu then fires
a bowl of breath at Luffy who Dodges
Mercado then jumps into the air and
attacks Luffy with conqueror of the
three World ragnaroku slamming Luffy
into the ground after this happens
Carter calls big mom pathetic for what
is going on between her and the others
but he still charges for Zorro demanding
he release Prometheus law however uses
his devil fruit to switch places with
him where he then uses injection shot on
kaido's throat he uses Curtin to Shield
himself but Karu still blows him away
while saying his powers are annoying
this opening does give Prometheus and
Napoleon the Gap to rush to Big mom's
Aid seeing them injured law says that
his plans aren't worth one of them dying
but kids says that they have already
succeeded and separating the two of them
as both him and Keller decide to take on
big mum by themselves finally we can get
rid of Big Dam out of this fight cuddle
laughs at how Luffy was glaring at him
while unconscious like back in bakura
town he starts talking about different
ways to maim him as zero tells law that
he has reached his limit so his next
attack will be his last Zorro then
coach's swords and conquerors haki and
performs his nine sword style form going
on to attack kaido with honestly one of
your most hyped moments in all of 2021
heading home with the Ashura blades
drawn Dead Man's game kado clutches his
chest and pain while screaming out
asking Zoro if he has conquerors haki
Zoro who was literally just yolt and
doesn't have a clue what he is talking
about falls down saying that he just
hoped the attack would have brought
kaido down as well kado however tells
Zoro that his attack will definitely
leave a scar on him he raises his
cannabo to attack as law tries to help
Zoro avoid it kado tells him it is too
late and blows the bow both of them away
were thunderbagawa after defeating the
two of them Kato says that if they had
joined him they could have taken over
the world together suddenly he hears
Luffy telling him that they would never
team up with him due to their friendship
with the samurai he thinks back to
higuru's training and advice on haki and
emits all the attacks he used on kaido
were shallow but after being struck with
his cannabo Luffy realized the truth
Karu could Infuse objects with
conquerors haki kado laughs and
confirmation as he charges at Luffy
revealing that only a select few
powerful individuals on the planet can
pull it off as he brings his Club down
on Luffy however Luffy having worked out
how to infuse conqueror's haki into his
limbs blocks the attack with his foot
without even touching it he then charges
ficado and punches him in the guts
without even touching him before
delivering an uppercut that seems him
absolutely flying slamming down onto his
back seeing this law is left in absolute
disbelief that Luffy did damage without
actually touching kaido Luffy thanks
both him and Zorro for covering him but
now they can go back down into the
castle he declares that he can handle
the rest as he will defeat kaido no
matter what after they leave carto gets
back up and smiles telling Luffy that he
seems to be enjoying this fight and the
higher the risk The Wider he smiles
these two of them charge at each other
and clash with the conquerors haki
infused attacks however only after a few
minutes of battling together again which
in typical odor fashion has been hidden
from us kaido stands alone as he remarks
that Luffy let his new power go to his
head however as the unconscious Luffy
Falls from onigushima towards the ocean
below cardo is actually regretful as he
knows that judo's failure to fully
finish the pirate off publicly his
allies will still maintain their hope
and belief in him as Luffy falls off
onikishima and into the ocean kado
states that although the pirate managed
to infuse his conquerors haki his usage
of it was crude and clumsy also going on
to say that he supposes Luffy could not
be Joy boy he then receives a call from
Huang who informs him that momonosuke
has been located Karu says that he will
head to the boy immediately and tells
Huang to announce the result of his and
Luffy's fight to all of onigushima so
after Luffy falls off onikishima he's
likely saved by the heart Pirates who
just happened to be in this submarine
down below because you know that that's
just their thing I guess and of course
we are going to skip past all of the
stuff that happens in between and pretty
much pick up on things right after the
moment that my king big Luffy is about
to ride his boy pause the now adult
momonosuke back up to the island from
this point on things get Ultra odor
style wacky and wild with some of the
most insane and hype stuff to come out
of one piece in literally years and I
mean freaking years like it probably
ain't been this hype for real since like
Marine Ford or at least as someone who's
binged the series in quick succession
like a crack kid after getting heavily
addicted to Luffy's spell back in 2019
this has been the most hype me so far
and I definitely think that I'm not
alone here anyways let's get back to
this Baddie down a tokake port below an
approaching onigishima the heart Pirates
panic when they see what appears to be
kaido and his Dragon form but Luffy who
will stand in front of the Dragon
realizes it is actually mominosuke while
crying shinobu explains that she gave in
to momonosuke's request and matured his
body by 20 years when Luffy asks why she
is crying shinobu says it is because
after her ability mamonosuke now appears
identical to someone of great importance
nevertheless Luffy asks momonosuke to
help him take back wano together what
she accepts after probably what felt
like an eternity for Luffy he finally
gets mom and uske to start flying and he
immediately starts heading towards
onikishima unfortunately for Luffy he
learns that mormonosuke is flying with
his eyes closed causing him to
accidentally crash into the live floor
and shocking everyone present having
lost complete control while monosuke
starts flying everywhere and tearing up
the Castle even breaking through the
second floor and surprising kid law and
big mum they eventually do reach their
third floor as the Beast part along with
everyone else Clement and confusion over
the presence of a second dragon
eventually the two reached the top of
skaldon just as Yamato who while Luffy
was away had been fighting has reverted
back to normal and charges at kaido with
Divine swiftness white serpent at the
same time momonosuke starts to land and
Luffy goes into his gear fourth Snake
Man immediately striking ikaido with
gumbo gamma no jet culverine both
attacks end up hitting kaido
simultaneously while at the same time
Luffy and Yamato greet each other with
Luffy thanking Yamato for keeping kaido
busy kaido recovers and turns into his
Dragon form questioning how Luffy is
still alive and who the new dragon is
Luffy yells to kaido that he won't die
because he will be the pirate king and
more monosuke introduces himself
surprising everyone as kaido tells
momonosuke that the world does not need
another Dragon Luffy tells momonosuke
something before jumping into the air
and striking carto with gumbo gamano
elephant gun knocking him onto the
ground momonosuke thinks about Luffy's
request which was for him to take a
cheeky bite out of kaido and after
thinking about the horrible things kaido
had done to him he Garners the courage
to bite down on kaido's booty causing
him to howl out in pain momonosuke
tightens his grip on kardo as he asks
him what he is doing but still while
afraid momonosuke refuses to back down
Luffy then comes in and Strikes Carter
with a conquerors haki coded first he
then calls the monosuke and points out
that he just bit down on one of the four
Emperors he asks if he is still afraid
of anything after doing something so
freaking insane and mononosuke realizes
that he no longer is Luffy then tells
him to stop onigushima in its tracks
while he promises to beat kardo himself
the alliance and Samurai who have been
watching this Rex with happiness at the
Revelation demon monosuke are still
alive and cheers Luffy on while
elsewhere big lump laughs at Luffy's
claim and kaido still expresses
disbelief at the idea of him having any
kind of chance against him kado and
Luffy then attack one another with a
conquerors haki not even touching one
another but causing the freaking Heavens
to literally split apart like this
proves that Luffy is bloody God's here
now it's like literally just said the
day Shanks met Whitebeard upon his ship
it's such an amazing show of growth and
I love to see him grow like this near
this Yamato and momonosuke watching ore
at Luffy and Carter's Clash this causes
Yamato and momonosuke to remember Odin's
writing about how Roger and whitebeard's
Clash split the heavens he's a freaking
God now boys our little Luffy has
ascended to the biggest of big leagues
now guys Luffy calls to Yamato to help
momonosuke and she agrees jumping on
momonosuke's head Carter refuses to let
them go anywhere and charges for the
both of them Yamato tries to encourage
momonosuke to get going what she
eventually does but only is Yamato ends
up blocking an attack from her father
seeing this Luffy wraps his legs around
kaido's neck in an attempt to hold him
back and Yamato quickly realizes that
Luffy wants a one-on-one with kaido so
with that she and momonosuke jump off
onikishima so as per our father odors
writing and skipped away for us poor
Margaritas from the main battle for like
two months here and I'm pretty sure
it'll be the same with when the anime
does actually get to the spot if not
longer due to filler and all that kind
of stuff that anime loves to do but when
we finally did get back to it it's
almost uninterrupted hands until the
final moment of the battle so yes on top
of the skull Dome Luffy and cardo
continue to fight and as luthi is struck
by kado's Club he manages to sneaky
punch in and sock him with Gamo gum on a
rock gun this causes them both to fall
to the ground and get back up laughing
with smiles on their faces as they both
confess they are having a lot of fun
skipping fought slightly to the point
where kado has now returned to his human
form and actually started drinking and
begins to annoy Luffy but he tells him
that he's drinking because he's having
fun and it reminds him of the banquet
they are originally having before
everyone ruined it after cardo smashes
back his drink he goes into his
lightning hammered mode and Luffy while
still annoyed charges at him hoping he
doesn't use getting drunk as an excuse
if he loses cardo however clarifies that
he drank because it would make him
stronger as he has finally acknowledged
Luffy's power in his drunken State Kato
Dodges an attack from Luffy encounters
with Drunken Dragon bargoa and lightning
hammered ragnaroku changing back into
his hybrid form and slamming Luffy into
the ground with chunks of the roof
falling onto the people still inside the
castle Luffy clutches his head and pain
as kaido becomes a full-on depresso
dragon going into his drowning Sorrows
mode lamenting on El harthi castle and
Ireland are destroyed because of his
inability to protect it and how it will
take another five years to rebuild
everything Luffy begins charging at him
again picardo uses Dragon twister
demolition breath to blow them back then
as he goes into his hybrid and tears in
his beers mode he attacks Luffy with
thunderbargoa but Luffy Dodges it and
kicks him Square in the face with a
conqueror's hockey coated foot though he
draws blood kado suddenly grabs Luffy
with his tail and brings him forward to
his face as they both headbutt each
other with conquerors haki sadly Luffy
is overwhelmed and blown back as he
admits that karo's haki is growing
stronger Karo then literally phases into
drunken rage mode as his array of
different emotions fly through and he
gets mad at Luffy for starting to sober
him up he fires a blast of energy atom
but Luffy Dodges and he charges Adam
with Gamo gamana Rock Gatling while
cardo counters with kundali dragon swarm
both attacks clash with Luffy and kado
getting hit by each other's abilities
however our boy gets a cheeky one in and
manages to strike kardo Square in the
stomach by the way I should mention this
here at the same time as this battle
both kid and lore are out double teaming
big dumb about to pile drive her ass
into the Enterprise of the planner
anyway don't worry about that I can do
that in another video if you want or
something someday on the roof after
Luffy and cardu's Clash cardi deduces
based on the shock wave nearby their big
come had been beaten by Kid in law which
Luffy praises the two of them four cardu
thinks back to the day he first met her
on the Rocks crew Luffy however goes
into his gear 4 snake man and uses gumbo
Gama no Hydra to strike kaido in
multiple places Luffy screams at him
that his dreams starved the people of
wino and with all the energy he has he
is going to make sure he'll never come
back to this country cuddle was
continuously pummeled by Luffy's attack
and when he blocks one punch he gets hit
in three more spots he admits his
attacks are hurting him as he realizes
that Luffy is altering the trajectory of
his punches at a whim he once again
tells him that his attacks hurt as he
goes into his drunken bigger mode which
angers Luffy at the fact that he is
still drunk kodu then goes into his
drunken Thief mode and transforms into
his full Dragon form where he then bites
and swallows Luffy in an attempt to
escape the onslaught he flies up into
the air and once he's high enough he
opens his mouth letting Luffy fall and
also firing Ebola breath at him the
attack pacing straight through the
island below and blowing Luffy down
through that hole Luffy however escapes
the blast and changes into his bound man
form to fly back up to kaido he declares
that this is his last key for and he no
longer has any time to waste to beat him
he yells to kaido that the people of
wano will continue to starve and go
thirsty as long as he remains here he
then prepares to use the move Gamo
gamono over Kong gun it's for kaido he
tells Luffy that while it's his business
who he teams up with he personally
considers the people of wano weak and
hopeless satini Samurai as losers who
would willingly die for the sake of
Honor Luffy retort this Samurai are
strong but Carter rejects this notion as
it repairs another bolo breath however
Luffy fires his attack first causing
kaido to misfire and side of his own
mouth and crashed to the ground Luffy
charges at him again but Carter quickly
gets back up and had some more Thunder
below bargoa causing Luffy to crash
steam starts to eject from his mouth but
Luffy tries to force it in as kardo goes
into his bloodthirsty drunk mode both
charge at each other again with Gamo
gamano over Kong gun and thunder below
bargoa but randomly someone I haven't
mentioned has been snaking around the
entire time the cp-0 agent finally
arrives and grabs Luffy's arm using
tikkai and the process to hold him back
though kado sees him he is unable to
stop himself from striking Luffy while
the agent steps back causing kaido to
phase into a flashback where he
remembers how Odin was distracted by
Higurashi during their fight and it is
the look of horror is shown in his eyes
the attack connects Carter's attack
causes Luffy's gear 4 to finally wear
off and as he returns to normal he lands
on the ground unconscious once again
with momonosuke even realizing he can't
hear his voice anymore though Carter was
named the Victor he was livid that has
to repeat itself again with him
achieving Victory due to another
person's interference he walks over to
the cp0 agent and asks if he is prepared
to face the consequences for his actions
the agent says nothing as kaido brings
his canalbo down on him with the
realization that the Battle Is Over Koda
descends the castle and his Dragon form
declaring to the samurai that Luffy is
dead and to make momonosuke step forward
and surrender to him the Beast Pirates
cheer for kaidu's victory while the
samurai despair with even kid and law
acknowledging This Bitter turn of events
while those like Chopper and tummer cry
for the loss of Luffy Nami refuses to
believe karo's words even revealing
herself to him to say so he fires a bowl
of breath at her but luckily one of the
coolest designed dudes in one piece
Uncle Marco shows up and blocks her
while yelling for everyone to not give
up until it is over Karu then declares
that onigishima will drop on the flower
capital and unlike Orochi he is going to
put everyone who lives in wano to work
to produce weapons his words cause the
Samurai's morale to waver as he once
again demands momonosuke presents
himself
when it comes to monosuke he decides
that surrendering might even be the best
option for everyone if Luffy can't beat
him anymore but Yamato retorts that even
a surrendering May save everyone present
eventually they will all die from
exhaustion as kaido slaves and because
of that she won't stop fighting even
claiming that kaido is at his limit too
she also reminds moinosuke that this
battle carries 20 years worth of weight
on the people of wano so with that she
would rather die than surrender
momonosuke accepts her words and their
battle rages on with him stopping
pulling the island away to rejoin the
fight suddenly like oh you ain't ready
for this one yet like if you're an anime
only oh my freaking God you were about
to instantot zunisha you know that big
ass elephant thing who walks through the
ocean speaks to my monosuke and tells
him that it can hear the drums of
Liberation for the first time in 800
years and proclaims that freaking Joy
boy has returned just as Luffy starts to
smile and steam starts coming out of his
mouth while an unknown substance starts
to envelop him which it sounds so bad
when you put it in that context rather
than a known substance there bro as
Luffy's heartbeat beats like a drum he
wonders how he is able to stand despite
having lost his fights with kaido and
also wonders how he is having so much
fun momonosuke meanwhile has told Yamato
while zunisha had told him that Luffy is
Joy boy and the pleasure Hall's right
brain Tower the sound of Luffy's
heartbeat wakes Sanji who immediately
calls his name elsewhere all throughout
the castle people hear Luffy's heartbeat
with some of them like Nami and Tama
crying tears of joy that is still alive
back with our hyped ass noodle head boy
their battle now resumes with kaido
stating that he was sure Luffy had died
to which the latter agrees he watches
Luffy bounce off the ground repeatedly
and deduces that he has awakened his
paramecia devil fruit since he is able
to turn his surroundings and to rubber
kardo knows that something does not add
up as Luffy's transformation should be
more reminiscent of a Zone user Karo
lunges at Luffy and attempts to devour
him but Luffy bounces around and is
insides using gumbo gamma Nobel fan to
actually expand not only his body but
Carlos as well Yamato and momonoska who
are sitting bearing witness to the work
of the gods are confused by what they
are even saying wondering if Kata was
getting fatter or if it was just one of
his forms while Carter becomes
frustrated with his body gaining the
properties of rubber and gum Luffy sees
two lights from inside him which turn
out to be his eyes he grabs through them
to latch onto his nose before using Gamo
gamono Escape rocket to free himself in
Carter's body he then begins to deflate
which sends him bursting up into the
clouds but instantly he re-emerges
through them as the size of a giant by
using Gamo gamano giant much to
everyone's astonishment kardo once again
bites Luffy but the letter takes
advantage of his size and kaido's
Serpentine 4 using Gamo gamano jump Pro
to use kado's body as a freaking jump
rope like dude's gone from dead to
pretending cardo is a skipping rope it
is actually insane as they descend back
towards the rooftop Kato fires another
bolo breath at Luffy which hurts him
directly and causes him to fall again
however Luffy becomes more frustrated
and begins spinning his legs so fast
that is able to run across the air to
return to the rooftop Brook can do
anything now as he prepares another
attack Karo strikes at him with
conquerors of the three worlds ragnaroku
sending Luffy's head crashing through
the ground into the lower floors much to
everyone's shock Luffy then pulls
himself back up through to the roof and
begins to revert back to his normal form
showing that he becomes extremely
fatigued and visibly ages after using
gear 5. kaido assures him that he can
actually die and someone will share this
story of this fight but Luffy refuses
stating that all that is left after
dying is Bones Yamato and see that it is
really Luffy but his hair and clothes
turning white made him almost impossible
to recognize As It prepares to
reactivate gear 5. Luffy reminds himself
of several people he has made promises
to or is indeed a two such as momonosuke
Tama Kenny Mon and Pedro Karu tells
Luffy though to be careful or he will
die but Luffy refuses to be afraid and
tells his heart to start beating even
louder allowing him to reactivate gear
5. he has suddenly struck again by
kaido's cannabo but this time his head
wraps around its weapon and the spikes
causing it to take a crescent-like shape
he begins running away in pain but
another Blow from kaido squashes him to
the ground yet Luffy uses the grout as a
springboard to launch himself back up
and towards a rock formation which he
once again launches himself off of to
return to his normal size kaido standing
there watching us still trying to make
sense of Luffy's new fighting style
watches as Luffy approaches him with his
arms spinning like helicopter blades
Luffy strikes kaido well they punch that
seemingly goes through his head before
knocking him to the ground while
remarking how fun this fight is Luffy
Ponders what to call his latest attack
as kaido picks himself back up he asks
Luffy who he is just as zunisha
reminisces to himself how familiar
Luffy's heartbeat feels and comfortably
reassures Joy boy that they can put
their trust in him while at the same
time Luffy proclaims his name and
declares himself as the man who will
surpass him and become the pirate king
kaido remarks how cheeky Luffy still
sounds and tells him that it is because
of his Awakening he also acknowledges
how much he's lost during this war
though feels Luffy has lost a lot too
but Luffy retort saying he will take
everything back that kaido has stole
Carter then uses kundali Dragon swarm on
Luffy while Luffy retaliates with
several punches that expand through
kaidu's body Karu then notices that
fumes have reached the top and realizes
that the entire Castle has caught fire
which means the alliance will burn to
death but Luffy confidently assures him
he can trust them to handle this
situation just as he Dodges a demolition
gust attack over with yarato she tells
momonosuke that kaido is reaching his
limit and he won't be able to sustain
his flame clouds for much longer which
means he has to produce his own flame
clouds now or else onigashima will fall
as she says that Luffy grabs a bolt of
goddamn lightning out of the sky like
his are now preparing to bring it down
on kaido as he watches from below
encouraging Luffy to actually attack him
with it like this fight is so freaking
good man it's so cool Cody remarks on
how Luffy was able to actually grab
lightning as Luffy uses a new move
called kamogama No Thunderbolt and heals
the lightning directly at kaido kaido
however sidesteps it and smacks Luffy
with his cannabo sending him flying off
only for Luffy to grab another lightning
bolt and swing around it like vikster
and the club and Bearcat kaido with his
inflated leg before can use another move
though Kato Dodges and Strikes Luffy on
the head where he declares that in the
end a strong devil fruit power isn't
enough to conquer the Seas revealing
that Goldie Roger himself had no devil
fruit power yet he was still able to
become the pirate king Luffy gets
repelled down onto the ground from the
attack which bounces him back up and as
he tries to defend himself Karu yells
that to conquer the Seas the one thing
that truly matters is haki he then hits
Luffy with the destroyer of death
thunderbargoa which injures him but
somehow he still grabs kardo and starts
dragging him up into the sky with him
only for kaido to try and Shake him
loose while changing into his full
Dragon form to blast him with dragon
towards the demolition breath
acknowledging that even with his
awakened power he's still weak to slash
in attacks while that's going on the
people of the flower Capital watch this
sky lanterns float up into the air while
the hope that their wishes will reach
the heavens as they know they will
return to being slaves tomorrow
cutter than blasts slothy with a bowl of
breath to get him to let go while
demanding he gets back down to the
ground now back down on the roof Luffy
tells more monosuke to get the island
out of the way as he inflates his hand
to a humongous size coated in haki and
an attempt to finally finish kaido
momonosuke though tells Luffy that he
can't move onikishima out of the way but
the memory of his family compels him to
try anyway kotto tells Luffy that he
will attack head on as he starts
covering himself in fire a move called
flame dragon torch while doing so he
tells Luffy that Odin died 20 years ago
by burning to death and ever since then
wano became a lawless land filled with
people desperately waiting for their
savior to appear the fire causes Luffy
to let go what kairu says is the right
call and that he had no intention of
running as it was because he was
confident Luffy wouldn't be able to
crush him with his fist and he would
vaporize it first cut within performs a
move called Rising dragon flame bargoa
as Luffy use Jesus gave birth gumbo Gamo
no bhajrangan all the while thinking
back to when hiroko taught him Advanced
Armament haki and in that moment the two
attacks Clash quickly skipping away to
the inside of the castle a rochi still
on fire tries to attack hiori but
dinjiro my favorite out of the scarebars
arrives in time and slices orochi's
final hit off ending The Psychotic
shogun's Reign for good surprisingly one
of the wishes that was written on the
sky lanterns I just spoke about before
was please make a roachy disappear well
another is free us all from this hell
which Luffy is still currently working
on in his clash with kaido as the two
continue clashing karuko means Luffy for
making it this far but he believes he
can never change the world however now
that kaido's Flames have completely
disappeared it means the island will
soon fall Karu then asks Luffy what kind
of world he wants to make just as
mominosuke finally produces his own
flame clouds and begins supporting the
island as is for Luffy he tells kaido
that he wants to create a world where
his friends can eat as much as they like
and as he says this his first tears
threw kaido's Dragon form and punches
him directly in the face sending him
straight and deep into the ground below
wino finally ending the long conflict
that has probably taken a lot more than
this straw hats ever possibly expected
and people in the general Community
outside of like anime and manga this has
been going on for years and it has
finally come to an end so shout out to
Oda for this freaking amazing fight man
it was Unreal it was like completely
completely unreal and certainly after
momonoski drops onigushima at a safe
distance on the flower capital and
passes out at almost the exact same time
as Luffy passes out from complete
exhaustion over with kaido who's now
slumped and is whole He remarks how he
told King in the past that Joy boy is
the man who will no doubt defeat him
though King constantly believed he would
never up here
well I think King may have been a little
freaking wrong about you know that one
obviously honestly this Ark in general
was just amazing and jam-packed with
some of the most hyped parts of the
entire one piece story so far and I
doubt unless something completely
insanely major happens sometime soon
like in the next like year or so nothing
will take this place as being one of the
greats until probably the last few of
the series with Shanks Blackbeard and
probably a bunch of those old dudes who
sit around together I can't remember
their damn names I just suspect those
old diesels are going to be strong as
hell as if you know any kind of mangaka
they either love making children
overpowered as hell or putting your
grandad on their demon level of strength
like just look at gup or pretty much any
old dude in one piece they are goated
strengthwise anyway anyway I hope you
all have enjoyed the video and if you
want more stuff just like this and you
want me to cover more one-piece content
in general let me know down in the
comment section below and try and smash
this video to like I don't know like 5K
likes or something and if we get to
there then I'll 100 I will do more
one-piece content and uh probably cover
all of like one or something like that
but anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate dear Volo and I
will see you all in a bit bye
[Music]